Sí buenas tardes María Clara lo has
dicho mil años tiene este Castillo es el
segundo en Europa más tiempo habitado
después del alcázar de Sevilla
construido por Guillermo El conquistador
el rey Normando que tuvieron los
británicos mil años y Por qué es
importante la historia de la Reina
Isabel porque fue aquí durante la
Segunda Guerra Mundial que ella hizo
hermana la princesa Margarita se
refugiaron mientras el pueblo recordemos
insistía que se fueran a Canadá que no
se quedaran Aquí sufriendo los
bombardeos aéreos de los nazis los
padres estaban en Londres y ellas
estaban aquí por eso quizás para ella
tiene una importancia especial también
era su Castillo favorito dicen después
del de balmoral en Escocia pasaba aquí
los fines de semana
montaba le gustaba mucho este Castillo
Ella hizo por ejemplo construir esa
capilla donde ya había pensado los años
60 que fuera su morada eterna junto a
sus padres como decía junto a su hermana
Margarita y ahora junto a su y lo hará
en esa capilla de Jorge sexto de su
padre es una capilla especial dentro de
la capilla de San Jorge y hoy un
analista decía que más que encontrarse
por ejemplo con su marido lo más
importante para la reina será
encontrarse en esta manera simbólica con
su padre que vivió muy poco para él era
para ella él era una roca era una
referencia y duró muy poco tiempo y
también a ella la obligó a asumir esta
responsabilidad muy joven de ser la
reina de los ingleses también a nivel
familiar aquí se realizan los
matrimonios bautizos funerales lo más
importante el de El príncipe Eduardo El
hijo menor de la Reina Isabel pero sobre
todo el más reciente el del príncipe
Harry con Meghan markle y recordemos que
desde el covid 19 la Reina Isabel se
vino a vivir aquí aquí pasó el
confinamiento y después ya Durante este
año se decidió que fuera su residencia
definitiva porque ella estaba muy
delicada de salud y también desde agosto
de este año aquí han decidido hacer su
casa El príncipe de William y Kate
middle con sus dos hijos ellos dijeron
que tomaron justamente esta decisión
para que sus hijos vivan mejor un poco
como pasó con muchas personas después
del 19 quizás se dieron cuenta ellos
también que Londres ya no era el lugar
para educar a sus tres hijos y quizás
aquí están más cerca de la naturaleza en
una ciudad mucho más pequeña y mucho más
acogedora que la gran capital britá